all right Garrett
Garrett uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um originally from
Antelope Valley born and raised tell me
about your family
uh mom is from Hollywood dad was like um
Orange County you know they ended up dad
was in the service the Navy
and uh ended up in Antelope Valley and
my mom too family moved out from
Hollywood to Antelope Valley how would
you describe your childhood
um my childhood I would describe it from
the ages I would say very good very
prominent and so my parents got divorced
out of
at uh for me for I was like four years
old and I remember up to that point
everything in my childhood was was
perfect
and then what happened
um
I remember sitting on the counter and my
parents explaining to us kids that they
were getting divorced and me not me not
knowing what that was as a as a child
and uh
and me and my sister uh were moving out
of this bigger home with uh you know
with the dogs and the horses and all
that stuff and I and I and I moved to my
mom and we moved into this this place up
the street
and um
and the difference in it and what
happened is I just remember coming home
one day and there was a man on on the
couch
[Music]
um
I don't know what to think I didn't see
my dad I don't remember seeing my dad to
too frequently after the divorce
and I remember this guy coming in to do
that stepdad role and uh and what this
brought and and I think like the
emotionalness and the and all this stuff
like it didn't hit I just remember going
to school coming home I I I remember I
remember not uh I remember like my not
having the stuff that other kids have
and wearing my mom's shoes my mom had
these Reeboks with the the two velcro
straps on the top and I and I remember I
needed shoes and uh and those fit me and
uh and I wore those
and I remember the kids making fun of me
at the school saying those are girls
shoes but I didn't care because they
were a lot comfortable there than the
shoes I had and uh and I and I know
after this is that um
from this point and and tell a little
further I know that uh the emotionalness
and the and the struggle of uh as a kid
trying to be able to talk to his parent
and to understand this uh this the
feelings that are going inside out this
child is developing and growing
and um one night you come home and um
and that guy is uh is drunk and your mom
is drunk and you're hiding in your room
and and this goes on for for time and
after time again and that and the abuse
and the yelling and the screaming and
and uh
I don't know how many times as a kid
that I moved around
uh how many times I had to run to a pay
phone as a kid or to the neighbor's
house or to somebody else's house to um
to call the cops
no
and uh I don't know how many times I I I
would talk to my sister and we'd be like
we're uh we're gonna run away
and um I don't know how many times that
that as a grown-up as a kid that every
place that where I was living where I
was living and where I was staying was
just was just like a place I did not
want to be
and um
my sister soon um
my dad you know we visit with my dad and
my sister went and lived with my dad and
uh I remember uh
I remember that day a lot
and uh now I really feel alone and I
feel the separateness and I
and uh
and I didn't know how much you know it
would affect me as a man later on in my
life being like this but um I'll tell
you that uh the drugs and the alcohol
and and the partying and all that stuff
that was in my was in my childhood
growing up was nothing was nothing that
I I thought that was normal for
everybody and ever since and uh and it
wasn't like I I thought that like the
fighting and the and the drugs and like
I thought like I I just thought it was a
normal I didn't know like the stuff that
I was hiding in my household and then
that and then and going to school and
are spending the night at friends houses
you actually had like dinner at a at a
kitchen table that had they had like
regular movie nights or they had they
had like they went on vacations like I
didn't know and I I don't know what
that's like
you know um
you know Tom was my uh my little sister
my mom Steven guy had a baby with this
Dad and I had this little sister and and
I just you know as being a kid still you
know I I played baseball for a season I
I played some soccer you know and uh
ah and I I tell you what I did a lot is
I rode a BMX bike around town a lot out
there and um
I know my mom had this little I had this
little sister of mine and I just know
that this kid that that was supposed to
be a kid and probably enjoying his
childhood and growing up with like the
stuff doing this stuff for kids a kid
does is is now uh is now becoming a man
and and he's and he's and he's taking
care of this little sister I just know
that my mom was gone
you know what leaving me in charge of
this little girl as you know and she's
going and she's coming back and she'd
get there just in time for me to go to
school
and um
I remember sometimes I wake up and uh
and in the mornings and I and I and I
try to wake my mom up so I can go to
school and
and uh
and uh and she just be like take the car
and park it at your bus stop you know
and um
and I didn't know man all the stuff that
I I like the the the the yelling the
screaming uh the the the different
boyfriends they know that that these men
like these my mom is is a single woman
taking care of these these kids and and
and as a strong woman as as your
everything as as a Young Man growing up
my mom was like in everything and I'm
watching these men as a little kid and
I'm watching them beat her and mistreat
her and and and all this stuff and chaos
and and I finally got to a point in my
and my youth
as a young adult
that I was able to look these guys in
the in the face or in the eye and uh and
tell them that um
that uh they're no longer going to be
able to lay hands on my mom
and um
and uh from that point forward uh I no
longer ran I no longer ran to the stores
I called the police I no longer ran from
this environment I what happened is that
I I get in this full-blown rage like
something would take over me as a as a
protector of my little sister and my
mother and I and I and I go through and
I I get in this rage and I and I and I
would just go like a like a like a wild
dog on some prey I go after these men
that my mom know and I and I and and
it's like a full-on rage and I couldn't
help myself
you know and um
and what that does to a kid is growing
up and uh and and emotionally and and
and vulnerability and and as a young
adult trying to the love and affection
trying to connect with somebody else I I
really think it it damages and hurts us
and stuff and and here it is is um and
then here comes and here comes the the
one thing that I didn't see coming
because I was one of those one since I
saw my mom always use it and my and my
dad's drink and I was like I'm not I'm
not going to do that
and everything I said I wasn't going to
do was the thing I did and uh before you
know it that that my mom's like my mom
had this guy and uh and um
a connection and and and like uh he was
like the father figure that I didn't
have and here I am I'm in junior high
I'm transferring from uh from eighth to
I'm transferring from eighth grade to
ninth grade they're only they're only
passing me because I'm so big so tall
and and they have to push me through and
and uh my relationship with my dad is
like I'm already partying I'm already
drinking I'm already I'm already smoking
pot I'm and I'm doing it at a fun as a
fun like it's it's enjoyment it's like
it's like how I meet people it's like
how I can get out of all this all this
low self-worth and low self-esteem and
all this wear that I'm feeling and I'm
finally able to uh I'm able to be part
of
and um
I know on my uh
first day of high school
I uh I walked
I was uh I was loaded
I was I walked up there to uh to get all
my classes and stuff myself my schedule
and um
it's about as far as I made it in school
you know
uh
I I go and um
for me as a young adult in the high
school I might like stuff happens in my
in the household no longer is uh we're
not no longer staying in the place we're
staying and I'm and uh and I'm on and I
remember man I I pushed this broom and I
and I seen some things probably kids
shouldn't see and and uh and and you
know and it's careful and it's
frightening in that relationship with my
dad's getting to be less and less he's
asking me those questions I have no
answers for and you know uh what do you
what do you want to do with your lives
like what are your goals and and I
didn't have I I couldn't think no that
stuff man uh
and for a kid like me I move into a I
move into Quartz Hill from uh out from
the outskirts of town I'm moving to the
city of Quartz Hill which is nothing and
I just start uh and I just start getting
involved in more of that street stuff
and uh more drugs more you know
marijuana I remember I'm I'm living in
this place we call it little Alcatraz my
my grandma lives in one unit we live on
the corner unit and then in the third
middle unit there's this guy he moved in
there he's a in his 20s and I I remember
I remember sitting there and uh and I
and what I do is I would get I I I I
found a different way to support the
means and Main you know of ways like uh
for a household and and to be able to
get the stuff I want I'm sitting there
at his house one night and I and I and
this knock on the door whenever he's
talking about this guy who's showing up
and and and who is this guy like who is
it like and he knocks on this door he
comes in and he's and he's and he's
tattooed and he's and he's humongous and
he has like a a couple people behind him
and and he comes in like and everybody
has like this
they respect this guy and like he has
this Aurora around him and I and I
remember sitting back in the distance
like I couldn't even meet him
and I was like that's that's who that's
who I want to be
now I want to be feared
you know uh I want that presence when I
walk in a room that people just sit down
and uh
you know I I
live this life um
I lived a life like I uh I remember like
they're the the first couple weeks of
the month were always really good maybe
with some meals and stuff and by the
last two weeks of the month it wasn't
that good and uh by this time I'm
showing up to my to uh the house you
know my mom and I'm telling that my
drugs are better than her drugs that she
should just buy them from me
uh by this time my High School uh uh you
know uh you know I'm a high school I I I
I just don't go I I go there for maybe
one or two periods and then I I leave
and um
and I'm like who needs School
I I have this buddy of mine who uh I
grew up the whole time like I've known
him for a long time and uh
and uh years later uh
I remember him picking me up from school
and uh
Joey Joey dystino and I go to and he
take me to these street races and I
remember watching this drunk driver hit
him
and killing them
at the street races and uh it was like I
made like this oath in myself that I I
never wanted to drink because of
watching this and um
I uh
tell you what happened for me is as a
child of a days of 14 15 years old like
I don't I don't know like I don't know
what age particular that I stopped
talking to my uh my dad or my stepmom
and people like that 14 15 he gets less
and less 17 I'm I'm uh Youth Authority
by the time I'm 19 I'm 20 years old I'm
I'm going to prison and uh
and um
man life's changed I still got this I
still got this emptiness inside me and
uh by this time I I think I you know uh
you know I I I I don't really nothing
going on I haven't talked to nobody I
just I'm I'm uh the drug addiction the
uh the the street lifestyle
you know um
I loved it you know and uh I get out
from prison and
and uh
I tell you like um
I don't think anybody's supposed to
to you know uh
see like the
I I meant to actually State Prison I I
go straight to a four yard I I I I I get
these good sell these I I you know like
I like I I I I once again I'm around
these guys and I and I and I just I'm
empowered I'm empowered by their power
and uh
and um
I'll do anything for them to accept me
you know and uh people always ask me uh
the questions after doing so much time
in prison like did you ever did you ever
stab somebody did you ever kill somebody
did you ever do that stuff and I'll let
you know is that uh I don't know because
I never stuck around long enough to find
out
um I I stabbed people uh I have uh did I
die I don't know
I don't know they haul them out on
stretchers afterwards I uh you know I
remember being on the streets and um
and uh and stabbing somebody was just
like a checking you know and uh I've
seen lots of blood and lots of and lots
of Gore in the prison you know uh I I
seen guys shot you know uh and during
the chow hall shot in front of me I I
seen guys beat with the with a little
brown cup I I seen I seen uh people stab
so many times I seen them sliced open
with with razor blades and and uh and
all this and all this blood and uh and
um I I I I tell you that the most
scariest moments I've been in are uh are
uh are some of the riots where
um
I remember telling some guys that I I
didn't even know like I I tell them
things like um like we might die
and uh like I don't know what's gonna
happen but I know at this certain time
that we're gonna we're gonna take off
and and we're gonna fight until and and
we gotta go until until the yard puts us
down
and um I stand you I Rise you rise
and um
I remember sitting there just covered
covered laying on the ground in the dirt
and uh covered and and and and and and
blood or whatever on the Hong Kong
Creator or in the dirt or in places and
uh
and um
identify as that rage that I felt when I
was
going after my mom's uh boyfriend's uh
because they were hitting her
not because they're raping her
um
that's the only kind of Rage that I I I
can identify it with
and um
it seems like uh
I I heard a lot of people out there and
um
I mean on the streets I
I uh at a very young age I I kick open
doors
in the middle of the night early
mornings I run into your room I grab
people out
um I uh
I beat people to a living pulp I
you know uh you know I I I
kidnappings uh stabbings beatings
you know and um
and to me it was all right
I Justified every single action I had on
that and um
from when the and when the drugs um you
know in and out of prison in and out of
prison the drugs come in and and uh and
I'm gonna tell you that that goes from
like trying to you're like somebody and
and I understand that there's hold of
the drugs coming at me and uh and uh
like this one lifestyle you got picked
out and then all of a sudden that is
it's this other lifestyle of uh of uh of
using like um
you know like I used to think that was a
job you know selling drugs the way I
used to sell drugs and lots of people
sell lots of people I I watch lots of
people you know dying and uh you know
and uh of this and I watch them
full-blown and addicted I I watch them
put a needle in their arm and I'd be
like not me
not me I'll never go that far with it
um
no I uh
I left those drawers I I once again I
get out of of prison and it vents out I
I I had a daughter I I I I couldn't I
couldn't get out of the disease I I I'm
I'm full blown and I'm a full-blown
addict
you know and uh I I drank and and I put
some drink and missed some liquor in me
and and I use and it doesn't matter how
hard I tried how how bad I wanted to be
a father or how about I wanted to to
have a you know a stable job or how bad
I wanted to beat up for my bad no matter
how bad I wanted to go see my my father
or my sisters I I I I couldn't
you know because I I have this Addiction
in me that I go out there I and I do
these drugs and I and I and I full blow
go on to the streets and I and I guess
my will I'm doing things that I you know
and justifying the things I'm doing and
I you know and I man I I just um I don't
know like we create and we become these
people that that uh we don't want to be
and we're out there living in that and
that stuff with this this undeniable and
unidentifiable stuff a character
characteristics of our that we grow up
in are inside of us then we're trying
and we're trying and that's like that's
like what we know we don't know and I
got this emotional and intense level
inside of me and I'm and I'm trying to
and I and that's I wanna know like I
like I like I don't know if I grew up
too much as a kid or what but uh but uh
life is life is going at me man and I
and and I can't stay out man I'm I'm
only I'm only staying I'm only staying
sober and not using drugs when I'm in
prison until I'm not
you know uh
and then uh
man I
man I uh
the disease and uh and then that
addiction it took me through all those
places all those rough places like uh it
didn't matter if I had a place to go or
or or or are people who loved me out
there like I I ran from those things
because a a person in an emotional state
and uh and and stuff that I win that I
got like I I to this day I'm still
working I'm I hold all this stuff in you
know and I and I'm working on on getting
it out there like it's it's hard for me
to talk about that emotional and deep
ingrained pain that you go through as a
child
and to be able to express yourself and
uh because I'm thinking that there's
people out there that don't come to an
understanding like me and they don't
know they they don't know what I'm
talking about and they don't know
because I because I don't know how to
express it
you know that people catch on to my
feelings and the way I am and that and
they and they and and and another thing
is is that is is like uh letting
somebody get close to me or allowing
somebody to love me
because those are all the things that
got you hurt when you're out there on
the streets
and um
man I I
bad
um
before I know it man uh that cool life I
was living out there man it was nothing
I ever got rid of that Rush of me
running at somebody's house early in the
morning or or from or from uh you know
uh hanging out a window with a gun and
in some apartment buildings and firing
up people or or being a driver in some
in some scenario you know because uh
they are running up into a whole motel
rooms and and kidnapping people out or
or uh are are walking into somewhere or
just and this and this and just beating
somebody up um that was like all the
stuff that I I loved and uh and then
that and then I start using and I use
and it was like oh all of a sudden they
start hitting me and and I can't man it
gives me chills like I and and it
paralyzes me because uh
because I know I'm very wounded on the
inside
and now I'm just trying to do drugs and
uh and drink to cover up all this pain
and stuff I got going inside of me and
uh where it takes me is uh it takes my
teeth it takes my it takes my Humanity
it takes my morals it takes everything
about a human being that I know and it
strips me off it and I'm out there on
the streets and I'm and I'm living in
the I'm living homeless in those bushes
and uh by choice I'm out there I I just
wanted to be isolated and to be able to
use and drink alone and and just I don't
want nobody bugging me
right because I hurt people
and I go out man and um
I know I I go back again once I get into
prison and uh and and that the fellas
and everything inside there and and we
meet and uh I I meet with a couple of
them on the streets and uh but I'm in
this vicious cycle man I can't stop and
I you know uh
um
and for anybody out there man that uh
that needs to know about that pain and
that and that that deep down condition
inside you that uh
that you know uh that only the drugs and
the alcohol can take away like I had to
do lots and lots and lots of work on me
to be able to feel part of society today
and um
you know uh
you know I I just love I I
man I I
one more time I'm uh
I go through and uh
I remember seeing the look of my
daughter's face as five years goes by
and she doesn't even really know who her
dad is and maybe see me like uh a month
out of five years
and um
and I used to be like man I I just it
breaks my heart and uh
I look at myself in the mirror and I see
me smile and uh it just look like a
Jack-o-Lantern and I I I have a friend
of mine he was like a mentor and for
some reason he uh
he's seen something to me he gave me
like a place to live and uh and a job
and and all this stuff and um
I couldn't stop
I couldn't stop drinking and using
I could I couldn't stop with that
lifestyle that I was so uh so used to
living
and um I'll say it today is uh today for
me is a very special day on being at St
Patrick's Day as today as I celebrated
10 years of uh being uh clean and sober
for being out of that life
and uh I'm I'm filled with so much love
and affection and all the stuff that I
that I I called my I called this
counselor 10 10 years ago that she said
to me she was like uh she's like why
don't you just sit still
and I called her yesterday and uh and
this this wave of emotion and and stuff
it came over me and
hello and I breathed and like and like I
started and I I started crying as a man
for how grateful I am for just stand man
and uh and being in this program and and
being able to have a purpose in life
because I felt like for a long time I
didn't have no purpose I felt like I
just had to be comfortable living inside
whatever whatever zone or wherever
whether it was homeless or was a a
prison or it was uh whatever environment
that I had I had to I had to be
comfortable in that environment and the
only thing I couldn't be was just me
right I uh you know uh
and and I'm grateful
for the program for me just Dan for the
people who've been here who who watched
this journey with me I I I'm I'm
grateful and uh and and and now I get to
talk about uh and uh as I as I come here
with you know with this amount of time
that I have that I own anything I've
Done Right is I haven't drank and I
haven't used and I and I come here and I
and and I and I learn more about
relationships
and uh I get to relate about how how bad
it was that uh or the way I grew up and
holding these emotions in and all this
stuff inside of me in and I and I get
you and I get you and I and the the
bottleness and that and that deepness
and like like how how how do I how do I
let people in
how do I let people in to to to see me
like it's so it's so hard like I it's
like I gotta have a great period of time
to somebody to be able to connect to me
emotionally or or or or or or or
something because I don't I don't know
how I don't know how to I don't know how
to let
people love me
and I don't know if it was something
when I was on the streets and I was out
there as I want to let people love me or
get close to me let alone know where I
was staying at and now I'm coming into a
life and I and I have these kids and I
and they and they love me man
there's many people out there who just
who like Garrett and love Garrett and it
and it and I still recoil from this from
this affection
I I coil I don't know what to do with it
and and I have to work through it
I've been I've been cut off emotionally
and I not to feel not to be able to talk
about those feelings not even the
feeling not to talk about those feelings
like I like uh
it hurts
and and you know I come here today like
man and I and I work with these other
guys and that
and they tell me they feel the same way
because for the longest time I thought I
was different
um
man I I I didn't start living I didn't
start living man until uh 10 years ago I
I uh I went with this uh Dolores Thomas
that counselor she had me go speak at
this place I became a advocate for
families in criminal justice and I and
she said that your experience can help
many others and of where you've been and
and what you lived through and the stuff
you saw and all that stuff is all the
stuff that I thought people want to like
me
you know all the stuff that all that
that drug addiction and all that all
that all that violence and all that all
that that hurting people and and and all
that all that all that stuff I thought I
thought that was something that was like
I don't I have to forget
but I thought I had to forget all this
stuff like so I had that I had to forget
it and I gotta take it I gotta box it up
and I gotta get rid of it and here I am
I I gotta take that stuff and I gotta
and I gotta find the key that I use
inside of me to unlock all this
emotional pain and I and I gotta pull it
out and I and I gotta put it there and I
and I gotta and I gotta look at it and
then when I look at it it brings back
more emotional and it brings back more
stuff and it makes me have to walk back
down to that to all that stuff I was
doing with these people and and I
man
the whole time I was running out there
man the one person I was running from
was me
the one person I was trying to hurt more
and more was was just me
like my my parents loved me
but I didn't think so my sisters loved
me
but I didn't think so
right
man I I'm uh
my I I don't look
and uh I don't sound
I don't um I don't live
I don't think
and I don't want to be that person that
I was back then and uh
and I and I speak and I come here and I
and and and I know and uh and and I want
to get raw with that emotion and those
feelings and and being who I am today is
uh is is great because I uh I love this
person I am today
and I would tell you the person I was
back then I wasn't loving that person I
was uh I was trying to die
like I I I I got to a point where that
drugs and the alcohol wouldn't work it
just substantia a state of mental
illness and inside my head it quieted
all down and I and I and I and I sit
there and uh
man I I I I I I I I I I do things like I
I go out there and I put myself in front
of this the danger or whether it be a
bullet or a or a or a robbery or uh or
Drive-In like uh or like like I I'd be
the front man in the prison on the right
I'd be uh like I I I I I I I
it didn't scare me
oh
today I don't want to die
you know and uh
man I my life today is is uh
is worth living
and uh
I'm not saying it's not easy I'm not
saying it's going to be no work I'm just
saying that I I come here and and and
and and and and I arrive here and I and
I say I gotta I gotta I gotta
continually I gotta continually build
and I I gotta can I gotta continually
break myself down and and build myself
up and uh and and and the areas of my
life that I destroyed at such a young
age like I my mom passed away and and
and and and my dad passed away and it's
so close together and I and I and and I
got to spend time with them I got to be
in their good grace like I got to make
these amends I got to I got to I got to
be the son that they wanted like they
always wanted to see I remember I
remember being at the hospital with my
mom and and and my son ran down the door
and I remember and there was nothing I
ever said
it was it was I I remember I turned I
picked up my son I turned around and I
and I saw my mom and I and our eyes met
her eyes are these eyes and they met
and I knew at that point that my mom
knew that something was different inside
me
like she had her son
and all those hugs with my mom and the
moments of Silence so that we can't
explain like I like I I can't change
none of that
like for so long like I I like maybe I
wanted to change if I only did this if I
only did that like if I if I if I didn't
do this like I I thought like I was in
the wrong for all this stuff I did like
and I wanted to change it and I had to
get in full acceptance and and be able
to be like this you know what like how
how can I better find a solution to fit
the problem that I'm in like why is it
that that I feel like why is it like
that why is it that my my head thinks
like this
is it is it is it from all the stuff
going from the from the from the you
know I I remember being in a truck in my
and my parents were fighting in the cab
and I'm in the back and we're and we're
going through this origin and like and
like and I'm yelling and I'm reaching on
when they're window and I'm I'm trying
to I'm trying to beat them you know or
or hit a tree or something you know like
uh like a you know a mom's screaming I
remember I remember my mom and her I
just I'd be locking myself in a room in
the silence and I and I and I I'd be
sitting there because they'd be out
there fighting and my mom would run in
my room and she and she grabbed my gun
and she always told me she'd be like you
know on your rifle leave your safety on
and I and I just remember I'm watching
my mom pull the trigger of this gun I'm
standing right behind her as a as this
drunk guys running towards her
and I'm watching like and if that safety
wasn't on that guy would be dead and I
and they crumbled through the door and
that and once again that rage Triggers
on me
and I go out to this guy man and I and
then at times like I I I I I pulled up
on this road and I and I see this guy
and my mom out there and I and I mean I
just full on this rage it
random dumb
I had to forgive that guy
Time After Time
that uh
years later down the road and uh and uh
I'm having I'm having breakfast after
another stint in prison uh and and I get
out and I I'm having breakfast with this
guy and uh and I had to forgive him
I had to forgive him
you know uh
who know and uh how much that affects
you know the the relationships with my
father and uh
what father
I left him I left him I left him
emotionally and and physically and
mentally uh probably at the age of 15
years old and I didn't I didn't really
talk to my father until I was 33 years
old
and talking about seeing somebody like I
I I
I remember I talked to him one time and
he asked me that question I didn't have
no answers for because I'm stuck living
then that like like how do you tell your
parents that I'm like I'm I'm addicted
to methamphetamine and heroin I can't
stop doing it and I need to like instead
of hurting you I'm not gonna talk to you
no more that I'm gonna go stay on the
streets to feed my disease how do you
how do you tell them that
so what I tell them is that I'll be
there for your birthday on Saturday for
your party
and I don't show up
and then I and then I tell them like hey
I'll be there for Christmas and I don't
show up
and after a while they just stopped
asking you
and after that long while I just stopped
I just stopped
and um
man I uh
I love the person I am today because
I've done some work and dig into these
emotions and these feelings of the
rawness
about being accept who I was and and the
things that I'd done and the
and uh I I you know I
I got some kids now and uh and uh you
know uh and I lived this life and I and
I and and I'm able to reflect back and
look at my life today of uh of having a
purpose
of being able to help and um
you know uh that people ask me they'd be
like uh do you believe in God
and I got you know uh uh 100 100 percent
and uh
people ask me things like um
do you ever think that if you're are you
ever gonna drink and use again I said I
don't I I said that I could only worry
about I'm not today
they asked me things like uh is there
anything that you ever would want to uh
that you didn't tell your mom or you
didn't tell your father that you wish
you would have I wish I would have gave
him more hugs and wish I told them I
love him a lot more
before they passed away
that time of his Essence and you don't
know what that time you're missing until
they're gone
and uh
that emotional state that of uh you go
through when uh when uh something
happens to your you know your parents
and um
there's no difference than that uh
been in the penitentiary
and having that person you're silly that
you call your brother
that like uh literally if I was to uh
drive down the street today I got a
couple studies that I if they were if
they were if their car was broke down
and and they and they were in the under
the hood of it and I was to drive by and
I saw their butt cheeks that I I would
know that's my selling
because I spent a lot of time with them
and to be able to watch that that
Brotherhood
of telling them that when these doors
open today I don't know if we're both
coming back
or leaving the child Hall like I don't
know for coming back
once again those those emotions get
inside
don't get close
don't tell anybody everything about you
I don't know where that came from from
the streets and I remember that guy that
I saw years ago and uh I saw this guy
and
with that hat and that and that trench
coat at my friend's house and he was
like the guy I remember I remember I'm
sitting with them and uh I'm getting
loaded with them selling guns together
and uh
I'd be like man I want to be just like
you
because I'm sitting there with them and
I I want to be just like you
and he'd be like you don't want to be
like me
and I I was like I I do want to be like
you
matter of fact like I want those tattoos
just like you
right
and you say Garrett do me a favor
he said look at me
I'm running from every every every law
there is known out there
you came and called me about my first
name
I changed my identity every every six
months I moved to different countries I
I like I you don't you don't want to be
me he's like I wish I didn't have none
of these tattoos
because they don't really mean nothing
and he's like uh
how about you don't get no tattoos
and you do the opposite of me
I couldn't understand how somebody would
say that
you know uh it's like my idol it's like
you're it's like you're it's like you're
it's like this person who you you know
who from the NFL or something that you
thought man like this I want to be like
you and this and this and this person
explains it to you and he's like but you
know like
no
you don't want to be like me
because we don't know they're emotional
and uh we don't know all this emotional
pain that the person's gone through to
be who he was and and and and and as
time goes by like I I
I'm proud of the man I am today
I accepted and and I'm proud and and I
love me as a human being today
and I I made one with that past
like I don't want to change nothing that
has happened in the past I don't I don't
want to because it's made me the man I
am today
but it really makes me want to work on
who I am today
to be a little better to have a better
understanding of the emotions and the
feelings I've gone through you know and
and in my head to this day like I like
my head's still crazy
it's very crazy in here man and I
man I
I love it man um
if you have a few friends then uh a few
friends in your life man you're you're
blessed if you have some kids in your
life that that that that call you dad
you are you're more unblasted if you
have uh you know if if you're able to
tell what size shoes you got what size
pants you got and able to brush your
teeth in the morning
have a bed to go in at night you're
doing pretty good
that means I'm doing pretty good and um
thank you for let me share it man
thank you Gary beautiful time